[Musik]
politisches beben in erfurt nehmen sie
die wahl zum ministerpräsidenten an
völlig überraschend wählte thüringer
landtag den fdp politiker thomas
kemmerich zum regierungschef ein schock
für den alten ministerpräsidenten bodo
ramelow für die linkspartei für viele
thüringer ein tabubruch heißt es in
berlin
denn die wahl von kemmerich war nur
möglich durch die hilfe der afg die
nachrichten des tages heute mit barbara
hahlweg guten abend und willkommen an
diesem ereignisreichen tag sport gibt es
auch in der sendung nachher mit norbert
leben
ein paukenschlag in thüringen mit dem
wohl kaum einer gerechnet hat und der
scharfe kritik proteste und den ruf nach
neuwahlen auslöste
zum ersten mal kommt ein
ministerpräsident mit hilfe der afg
einer in teilen rechtsextremen partei
ins amt der fdp politiker thomas
kemmerich
zur erinnerung die fdp hatte es bei der
wahl im oktober nur ganz knapp mit
gerade mal fünf in den landtag geschafft
stärkste partei war die linke von
ministerpräsident ramelow
er wollte eine minderheitsregierung der
koalitionsvertrag war fertig
unterschrieben gestern auch von spd und
grünen
doch der kann jetzt ins altpapier die
ereignisse in erfurt fast tagen nicolas
zusammen es ist ein politisches erdbeben
mit fdp chef thomas kemmerich wird
jemand als ministerpräsident vereidigt
mit dem kaum jemand rechnete der 54
jährige führt die mit fünf abgeordneten
kleinste fraktion im landtag bei der
wahl im oktober schaffte die fdp knapp
die fünf prozent hürde
und nun soll sie eine
koalitionsregierung organisieren die
fortsetzung der rot rot grünen koalition
unter dem bisherigen amtsinhaber bodo
ramelow ist nach drei wahlgängen
gescheitert und das durch stimmen der
afd
rot-rot-grün ringt um worte die
thüringerinnen und thüringer haben
eindeutig mit ihrem wahlergebnis zum
ausdruck gebracht wen sie als minister
haben wollen und was die fdp hier für
ein spiel getrieben hat das missachtet
einfach den wählerwillen alles kam so
gegen den bisherigen linken
ministerpräsidenten ramelow tritt
zunächst der parteilose
ortsbürgermeister christoph kindervater
für die afg an
im dritten wahlgang stellt die fdp
thomas kemmerich als kandidatin auf er
erhält 45 stimmen eine mehr als bodo
ramelow der afg kandidat kindervater
bekommt 0 stimmen denn alle fdp
abgeordneten stimmen für fdp-chef
kemmerich die cdu sieht die wahl käme
rix gerechtfertigt wenn zwei kandidaten
zur auswahl stehen von der afg und von
der linkspartei
und es gibt ein angebot aus der mitte
dann ist es nur folgerichtig dass die
cdu die sich als partei der mitte sieht
auch diesen mitte kandidaten unterstützt
unter zwischenrufen nutzte der präsident
thomas kemmerich seine erste rede vor
dem landtag für distanzierende worte und
seine vorstellung einer
minderheitsregierung eine einladung an
cdu spd und grüne aus gemeinsam
staatspolitische verantwortung für
thüringen wahrzunehmen
wer kemmerich gewählt hat hat ein
erbitterten gegner von allem gewählt was
auch nur einen hauch von radikalismus
rechts wie links faschismus aufweist
während die cdu zur zusammenarbeit
bereit ist haben spd und grüne ihre
ablehnung erklärt
matthias kubitz erfurt wie haben sie
diesen wahltag erlebt wie reagieren die
thüringer ja also ich habe heute sehr
viele schockierte gesichter gesehen auch
wut und tränen vor allem bei rot rot
grün bei der afg vor allem bei der afg
auf der anderen seite auch triumph
triumphgefühle
nach diesem ergebnis und dann als thomas
kemmerich seine erste rede als gewählter
ministerpräsident hielt da war dann
tatsächlich diese nachhaltige vergiftete
atmosphäre zu spüren
im landtag also hämisches lachen wie
wütende zwischenrufe auf der einen seite
aber auch auf der anderen applaus wieder
da auch vor allem von der afd
im moment stehen wir hier vor der
thüringer staatskanzlei linke gruppen
haben spontan zu einer demo aufgerufen
haben einmal die staatskanzlei umzingelt
und es sind rufe zu hören
kemmerich tritt zurück und ein wirklich
politisch brisanter tag beschäftigt
natürlich auch die thüringer bürger und
satz haben wir nachmittag mal in einer
umfrage abgefragt also ich bin geschockt
dass es soweit gekommen ist und ich bin
entsetzt dass er sich von der afg hat
zum ministerpräsidenten wählen lassen
und die wahl auch noch angenommen hat es
geht weniger um ihn sondern wie er
zustande gekommen ist wie die wahl
zustande gekommen ist das also meinen
augen sich die cdu verantwortungslos und
in korn der fc hat spannen lassen um rot
rot grün zu verhindern
aber was uns als nächstes ansteht ich
weiß nicht also unsere hoffnung liegt
eigentlich auf neuwahlen
soweit die stimmen aus erfurt danke
schön herr kubica auch das politische
berlin bebt die cdu kritisiert die
eigenen leute in thüringen das präsidium
der partei empfiehlt einstimmig
neuwahlen von einem inakzeptablen
dammbruch sprich die csu auch spd grüne
und linke sind entsetzt nur die afd ist
begeisterte aus berlin wenige schaffen
die wut bei einigen groß die grüne
franziska brantner lässt sie an wolfgang
kubicki aus der für seine verhältnisse
fast sprachlos wirkt
würde ich zu grunde schon würdiger
zurück will dann würde ich heulen und
ihn zum rücktritt auffordert durch das
treffen sie auch gerne macht in
demokratie sieht das nicht vor
die verfassungsordnung bis man in der
fdp parteizentrale auf die vorwürfe die
hier bis an die tür stehen reagiert
vergehen einige stunden dann ein versuch
der abgrenzung ein wenig zu den eigenen
leuten in thüringen mehr noch zur afd
wir unterstützen die ziele und werte
dieser partie nichts
wer umgekehrt unsere kandidaten in einer
geheimen wahl unterstützt
das liegt nicht in unserer macht auch
die cdu chefin als zunächst an den
kameras und nachfragen vorbei auch sie
versucht dann die verantwortung ganz
nach thüringen abzuschieben
das verhalten der cdu in thüringen im
dritten wahlgang geschah ausdrücklich
gegen die empfehlungen und gegen die
forderungen und bitten der bundes partei
das will ich noch einmal ganz klar
stellen für die spd bleiben denn noch
viele fragen offen
es geht nicht mit einer kommentierung
dessen was passiert ist es geht auch
nicht mit verdammen des ergebnisses und
dann weitermachen als wäre nichts
geschehen wäre
und in bayern dass man stinksauer auf
die schwesterpartei die cdu erleidet
damit einen hohen maß und
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust für die csu kann
ich nur sagen wir werden uns an keiner
solchen abenteuer sollten sie hier auf
bundesebene anstehen in irgendeiner form
beteiligen ganz im gegenteil wir lehnen
ein solches verfahren ab die afg spitze
aber jubiliert genau das gegenteil habe
man ja heute bewiesen die ausgrenzung
der stehe als undemokratisch ist an dem
heutigen tag gescheitert
bernd riexinger wollte eigentlich auf
eine demo nun steht die linke darf ohne
ministerpräsident
es war eine der besten tricksereien und
betrug am willen der wähler und
wählerinnen in thüringen was wir heute
dort erlebt haben
ob thüringen eine blaupause für mehr
sein kann dass es nun der große
politische streit in berlin
ja fragen wie konnte banerjee in berlin
welche bedeutung hat diese wahl für die
große koalition
ja also dieser vorgang ist hier wirklich
mit wucht in die große koalition rein
gekracht die ja ohnehin schon nicht
wirklich harmonisch gewesen ist in den
letzten monaten und wochen und wir hören
heute wieder das ist
auseinandersetzungen gibt und
forderungen aus der spd
man sollte doch wieder rausgehen aus der
großen koalition also dieses wort steht
hier wieder im raum selbst olaf scholz
der vizekanzler der hier immer ein ganz
entscheidender vertreter der großen
koalition gewesen ist hat heute auf
twitter gesagt das ist ein tabubruch das
ganze und es stehen jetzt wichtige
fragen ernste fragen im raum und es
erfordert schnelle antworten wie sieht
es in der fdp aus die freuen sich ja
auch nicht über ihren
ministerpräsidenten
ja das kommt wohl drauf an wie man fragt
christian lindner hat ja sehr deutlich
gesagt dass es erstmal ein gutes
ergebnis für die fdp und hat den ball
weiter geschoben an cdu spd und grüne
und hat quasi gesagt wenn du jetzt nicht
wollen dann kann man mal über neuwahlen
nachdenken er bekommt auch unterstützung
aus der bundesspitze dafür aber es gibt
auch andere stimmen die kommen zum
beispiel aus dem bundestag die sagen
heute ganz klar das ziemt sich nicht für
liberale sich von der afg mit wählen zu
lassen und die nordrhein-westfälische
fdp hat sogar per pressemitteilung
schriftlich herrn kemmerich dazu
aufgefordert zurückzutreten und den weg
für neuwahlen freizumachen
also da baut sich jetzt gerade selbst in
der eigenen partei eine ganze menge
druck auf der in den nächsten tagen noch
zunehmen könnte dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus berlin schock und anna
banerjee politischer paukenschlag in
thüringen dazu gibt es ein zdf spezial
direkt nach uns um 1920 in die usa wie
tief dort mittlerweile der graben
zwischen republikanern und demokraten
geht zeigte sich bei der traditionellen
rede des präsidenten zur lage der nation
klar inklusive und zwar in zwei akten
erst ignoriert präsident jump die
demokratische mehrheitsführer reid
pelosi und dann nach der rede zerreißt
sie demonstrativ sein manuskript mutter
jäger über einen denkwürdigen
im us-senat trumps redemanuskript hatte
sie vor aller augen zerrissen
warum ist die frage an nancy pelosi
direkt im anschluss weil es ein manifest
der unwahrheiten war zuvor spricht trump
vor beiden kammern des kongresses also
auch vor denen die ihn des amtes
entheben wollen kein handschlag für die
demokratische widersacherin kein platz
für höflichkeiten trump lobt seine
regierungsarbeit die botschaft alles ist
großartig
die einkommen gehen in die höhe die
armut geht zurück es gibt weniger
kriminalität zuversicht kommt auf das
land gedeiht muss endlich wieder hoch
angesehen und gibt sich präsidial und
schaltet doch immer wieder im
wahlkampfmodus er schießt gegen die
demokraten spricht mehrfach von
radikalen linken an die die heute abend
von zuhause zu schauen
wir werden nur zulassen dass der
sozialismus die gesundheitsversorgung
zerstört immer wieder stehende ovationen
auf der einen hälfte des saals stille
auf der anderen
applaus von allen aber für den
überraschungsgast venezuelas
selbsternannte im interims präsidenten
breido sagt schwank weitere
unterstützung zu am ende gibt er ein
versprechen
liebe mitbürger das beste kommt erst
noch
chemnitz den kongress als wahlkampfbühne
pelosi reißt seine rede buchstäblich in
stücke in ein paar stunden kann sich
schon feiern lassen
ein freispruch im
amtsenthebungsverfahren ist ihm so gut
wie sicher und noch einen nachklapp zu
den demokraten die hatten bei den
vorwahlen war bei der auszählung ja
massive technische probleme jetzt gibt
es teilergebnisse demnach legt
überraschend der junge eher unbekannte
ex bürgermeister peter ditsch vorn auf
platz 2 companies anders wenn alle man
alle wahlbezirke ausgezählt sind ist
noch offen
zum corona virus das breitet sich weiter
vor allem in china aus dort sind nach
behördenangaben jetzt 490 menschen daran
gestorben
als 24.000 haben sich infiziert auf
einem kreuzfahrtschiff vor japan wurden
neun passagiere und ein crewmitglied
positiv getestet sie wurden in ein
krankenhaus gebracht 3700 menschen auf
dem schiff stehen unter quarantäne unter
ihnen acht deutsche
ein passagier hatte das virus an bord
gebracht
am istanbuler flughafen sabiha gökcen
ist eine boeing 737 von der landebahn
abgekommen
nach offiziellen angaben wurden
mindestens 52 passagiere verletzt
177 menschen waren an bord der
türkischen pegasus maschine als das
flugzeug in drei teile zerbrach und
teilweise feuer fing
die maschine kam aus ist mir der
flughafen wurde nach dem unfall
geschlossen
nach london da lassen brisante
erkenntnisse zum fall julian assange
aufhorchen
dem wikileaks gründer wird ja
geheimnisverrat in den usa vorgeworfen
auch gab es ermittlungen in schweden
gegen ihn wegen verdachts auf
vergewaltigung flüchtete 2012 in die
botschaft ecuadors in london 2009 10
wurde ihm das politische asyl dort
entzogen seitdem sitzt er in
auslieferungshaft
kurz vor prozessbeginn in london sagt
der un-sonderberichterstatter für folter
die vergewaltigungsvorwürfe in schweden
waren erfunden
andreas stauff julian assange
herausgezerrt aus der ecuadorianischen
botschaft in london
dort hatte sich der wikileaks-gründer
jahre lang dem zugriff der polizei
entzogen
ein flüchtiger mutmaßlicher
vergewaltiger hacker spion habe das
verdient so der tenor in vielen medien
doch das sieht der
un-sonderberichterstatter für folter
anders also ist ein moderner
hexenprozess und der zweck ist ein
exempel zu statuieren und
sicherzustellen dass eben die medien
nicht unkontrolliert
informationen veröffentlichen über über
das verhalten von staaten zwei jahre
recherchiert melzer den fall wegen eines
vergewaltigungs vorwurfs in schweden war
assange in die botschaft geflüchtet er
fürchtet nicht schweden sondern von dort
in die usa ausgeliefert zu werden doch
die anschuldigung fuße auf manipulierten
beweisen per mail ordnet ein ranghoher
schwedischer polizist die verfälschung
eine aussage eines angeblichen opfers an
erstelle ein neues verhör füge den text
ein und ordne das verhör den akten zu
signieren das verhör auch das verfahren
wird 2019 eingestellt mars ist da in
london schon in einem schnellprozess
wegen verstoßes gegen kautionsauflagen
verurteilt rechtsstaatliche grundsätze
seien in mehreren ländern über bord
geworfen worden und die
rechtsstaatlichkeit diesen unseren
ländern durchaus gegeben solange die
essentiellen staatsinteressen nicht
betroffen sind
sobald sich der staat aber in seinen
sicherheitsinteressen bedroht fühlt
fundamentalen und ich denke die
wikileaks veröffentlichungen waren
wurden also eine solche wahrgenommen
dann funktioniert das nicht mehr weder
schwedische noch britische behörden
haben auf die vorwürfe reagiert auch
nicht auf den vorwurf der psychischen
folter an dem so der un
sonderberichterstatter es einzig und
allein keinen zweifel gebe und noch eine
meldung in eigener sache wie kann man
journalistische inhalte am besten
digital vermitteln im netz etwa in
nachrichten apps mdr und zdf arbeiten
dabei jetzt zusammen mit der
innovations- und digital agentur kurz
wieder im april soll es losgehen in
leipzig kündigten zdf-intendant bellut
und seine mdr kollegin wille an an den
start geht es mit 15 mitarbeitern ein
zweiter standort ist in erfurt geplant
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
nannte das ein deutliches bekenntnis zu
den neuen bundesländern
und damit sind wir beim dfb pokal
norbert der gestern leider auch massiv
unsportlichkeiten der rassismus vorfall
gestern abend in gelsenkirchen der
überschattet den achtelfinal sieg der
schalker gegen hatte der berliner
verteidiger jordan torunarigha soll aus
dem schalke block unter anderem mit
affenlauten beleidigt worden sein
der dfb kontrollausschuss ermittelt
es ist diese szene aus der verlängerung
die im gedächtnis bleibt
jordan torunarigha sichtlich aufgebracht
und nicht zu beruhigen
schalker fans hat nun während des spiels
rassistisch beschimpft worden war sehr
hart man muss sie nur in die augen
schauen dann im spiel das war s dann
wahrscheinlich er durchlebt torunarigha
sieht für seine reaktion gelb rot
hertha-geschäftsführer michael preetz
sagte heute in einer stellungnahme
er habe das schiedsrichtergespann vor
der verlängerung über den vorfall
informiert und gebeten den spieler zu
schützen
schiedsrichter harm osmers wollte sich
dazu nicht äußern eine stadiondurchsage
oder gar einem spielabbruch wie es die
fifa regularien vorsehen veranlasste er
aber nicht mir fehlt jegliches
verständnis für leute die sowas touren
und ich kann mich nur bei dem jungen im
namen von schalke 04 entschuldigung das
achtelfinale endete 3 2 für schalke und
dem rassismus fall torunarigha ermittelt
jetzt der dfb-kontrollausschuss schon
wieder eine schwarz-gelbe pokal pleite
im achtelfinale schon wieder gegen
werder
364 tage nach der bvb- heimniederlage
gegen bremen scheitert die borussia auch
im hexenkessel weser-stadion der
wiedergewonnenen grün-weißen
begeisterungsfähigkeit hat dortmund in
dieser magischen pokal nach zu wenig
entgegenzusetzen
erstaunlich selbstbewusst der sv werder
die 2 0-pausenführung durch zach und
bittencourt lässt ganz bremen schon vom
neuerlichen fußballmärchen träumen
dortmunds anschlusstreffer durch
wunderstürmer holland contra sitzer mit
dem 3 zu 1 bevor rehnas traumtor zum 3 2
eine wilde schlussphase einleitet der
bvb fiebert auf den ausgleich aber pass
lenker im bremer tor hält den sieg fest
[Applaus]
dortmund also raus aus dem pokal ein
herber stimmungsdämpfer nachdem so guten
rückrunden-start und bvb kapitän marco
reus fällt nach seiner verletzung
gestern abend auch noch mindestens für
vier wochen aus und schicken wir gute
besserung und blicken jetzt noch wie
immer mittwochs lotto
die gewinnzahlen lauten 13 16 31 37 39
49 und die superzahl 7
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
gleich beim wetter von osten telli der
wärmste januar weltweit und stürmische
aussichten im heute journal um fünf vor
10 spricht marietta slomka mit der cdu
parteivorsitzenden und mit dem neuen
thüringer ministerpräsidenten geht es
gleich weiter mit dem zdf spezial zum
politischen beben in thüringen wir
danken für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen
noch einen sehr schönen abend und
sanchez
[Musik]
ein schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter aus physikalischer
sicht ist es kein wunder dass die erde
sich weiter erhitzt denn die
treibhausgaskonzentration erhöht sich ja
auch immer weiter und schauen sie mal
richtung sibirien und russland die
temperaturabweichungen sind hier enorm
dass genau in den permafrost gebieten
ja und der januar 2020 war der wärmste
global betrachtet der wärmste januar und
auch europaweit war es der wärmste
januar bisher aus der vergangenheit
schauen wir jetzt in die zukunft in die
kommende nacht da gibt es viele wolken
im norden im süden eher weniger im
westen da bildet sich teils dichter
nebel und knackig kalt wird es an den
alpen bis minus zwölf grad fünf grad
sind es an der nordsee morgen gibt es
schon mal im süden viel sonnenschein
weiter nach norden in der norddeutschen
tiefebene etwas sprühregen schneegriesel
in den östlichen mittelgebirgen das bei
temperaturen von null grad im vogtland
und 9 grad in schleswig-holstein die
nächsten zwei tage sind relativ ruhig
aber dann am sonntag kommt ein neuer
sturm viel regen und werte bis 15 grad
damit ein schöner abend